Do or do not there is no try
size matters not. look at me judge me by
my size do you?
for my Ally is the force and a powerful ally it is.
life creates it makes it grow, its
energy surrounds us and binds, luminous beings
are we, not this crude matter you
must feel the force around, here between you, me
everywhere. Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is going to be my video all
about Yoda's species on the mandalorian
and in the Star Wars Canon because this
is taking place right after Return of
the Jedi so a lot of people are
wondering if it's going to connect with
stuff that's happening during the new
trilogy in rise of Skywalker I am doing
videos for all the Mandalorian episodes
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
we're also doing a Star Wars merge
giveaway too so obviously careful for
spoilers from the Mandalorian if you
haven't seen it yet
Lucasfilm technically lifted the spoiler
ban on talking about baby Yoda but
that's basically what it was people were
just waiting til after the first couple
of weeks to start openly talking about
and posting pictures of baby Yoda but
just to be clear even though the
Internet has largely dubbed this person
baby Yoda we don't know that he is the
biological child of Yoda we don't know
that he's a clone of Yoda but I'll
discuss that during the video so this
scene is all about the Mandalorian being
saved by the young link that we're
dubbing baby Yoda and during a big
callback to Yoda lifting Luke's x-wing
out of the swamp and Empire Strikes Back
saves the Mandalorian from being crushed
by the mud horn creature by lifting it
in the air with the force then stunning
it when it drops to the ground long
enough for the Mandalorian to finish him
off baby Yoda promptly passes out
because the effort taxes him so much
you're basically using your life
to do stuff like this which is why Luke
Skywalker died in the attempt to project
himself across the galaxy to help give
the resistance time to get away
baby Yoda is fifty years old according
to what they're saying on the TV show
that makes him around four or five years
old in human years assuming that he ages
at about the same rate but he can't
quite talk so the planet kind of fast
and loose in terms of how fast he
develops relative to other races because
he can climb out of his hovering
bassinet he can walk on two legs he can
capture an e food by himself like we see
when he snarfs down that giant frog
relative to his size the frog is almost
as big as he is then he's also able to
tell when the Mandalorians in trouble
he's able to use the force to sense
what's going on with him even though he
himself can't speak yet the only other
two members of his race that we've ever
met anywhere in the Star Wars universe
in any kind of Canon even the legends
Canon or Yoda himself who was about 900
years old when he died then ya know who
we last saw during Phantom Menace and
she was a little under five hundred
years old when that happened there's a
story about what happens to her after
this moment but they got rid of her
during the legends timeline and even
though that isn't canon anymore she was
actually just referenced again during
Star Wars fallen order if you've been
playing that game they reference the
adil in passing during it someone thinks
that she's still alive out there
somewhere but that's it George Lucas has
always refused a lot of questions about
Yoda's backstory where his race comes
from things about his people like you
would normally ask questions about the
other races of the galaxy he's been very
meticulous in at least working with
other third parties in building out the
backstories behind all these cultures in
the galaxy but when it comes to Yoda
species it's a hard pass the only time
he's ever allowed or given his blessing
to creating a new member of the race is
during the Mandalorian species that
might be because Dave Filoni is working
on the show and he sort of George
Lucas's adoptive son George Lucas no
joke thinks of Dave Filoni as the son
that he never had because George Lucas
only has daughters but a lot of people
are now wondering if this baby oda if he
survives the Mandalorian series which it
sounds like he will if he's going to be
the future of the Jedi Order for the
next 850 years which takes it way past
the rise of Skywalker and because of
some Easter eggs from episode 1 on
Doctor Pershing's in Pierrot uniform
there are a lot of theories about who he
is and what the Empire's plans for baby
Yoda are
so if you missed this during episode one
Doctor Pershing is wearing a white Imperial
medical officer's uniform with a special
symbol on it that denotes the cloning
facility a Kamino from attack of the
clones implying that he worked in
cloning research for the Emperor now as
of right now in the show the empire has
fallen after the Battle of Endor in the
battle of jakku what remained of the
Imperial fleet has since gone into the
Unknown Regions and they're in the
process of becoming the first order so
they're nowhere to be found
The Imperials that we see on the
Mandalorian are just the leftovers who
are vying for power now the moths the
Admirals trying to consolidate what's
left of the Empire the way Werner
Herzog's character refers to it and he's
wearing him Imperial medallion is bring
back a sense of order go back to the way
things used to be under imperial rule we
know that the Emperor had all kinds of
secret projects all over the galaxy
hidden from the rest of the Empire he
was obsessed with immortality Q the
Darth Plagueis the wise speech and he
was obsessed with the knowledge of the
force that being said is much contempt
as he showed for Master Yoda during
brunch of the Sith because Yoda's race
was so powerful in the force Emperor
Palpatine tried to learn everything he
could to exploit that or in lieu of that
get rid of all the other members of his race
top that would pop up because they were
potential threats to him if every member
of Yoda's race is just as force
sensitive as he was and capable of being
just as powerful it's a huge threat to
the Empire when Palpatine seemingly died
which we know now didn't stick because
he just showed up in the flesh during
the rise of Skywalker trailer a lot of
these secret projects that the Emperor
was working on sort of burst at the dam
because he wasn't there to keep them
secret anymore
so a lot of people working on those
projects or who had knowledge of them
tried to exploit them in his absence now
a lot of people are wondering if Doctor
Pershing is either going to try and
clone baby Yoda to make an army of force
sensitive beings that the remnants of
the Empire are able to use to maintain
order a bunch of evil tiny Yoda's
running around with lightsabers or if
baby Yoda himself is a clone of Yoda is
part of that attempt after watching the
episodes a couple times I'm starting to
think less that he's an actual clone of
Yoda but that they do want to clone him
and the reason that he's a foundling
just like the Mandalorian is because he
lost his parents they were killed
sometime between the prequels in the
original trilogy during the purge if
he's 50 years old
that makes them about as old as Anakin
Skywalker so baby Yoda predates the
prequels when the Mandalorian took the
job. Doctor Pershing insisted that he be brought
back alive and that probably has
something to do with the viability of
the cloning process like living
biological matter is easier to clone
than dead matter the reason why Werner
Herzog's character is totally cool with
him being dead is probably because
either doesn't care about this army of
clones Yoda's or he doesn't think they'll
be able to control them there been a lot
of jokes about Yoda maybe getting with Y
Adil but the thing is is that even
though they're male and female members
of their species and they reproduce like
normal mammals would with male and
female the reason why I don't think that
baby Yoda is actually Yoda's biological
child is because Yoda made such a big
deal about the tenants of the Jedi Order
and one of the core ones was that they
were never allowed to have children so I
think at least Master Yoda would have
respected that
yato left the Jedi Council after Phantom
Menace she might still be alive like I
said she's mentioned during Star Wars
fall in order by someone thinking that
she's still alive after the great purge
after order 66 but that hasn't been
confirmed yet because of George Lucas
keeping them secret nobody really knows
much about their race not in real life
and not within the Star Wars universe
like the other Jedi Masters and
historians don't know much about Yoda's
race themselves because of their in
fibia slight qualities we know that they
come from very swamp like planets like
Dagobah was the perfect planet for Yoda
to hide on one because it helped mask
his force signature because it was so
strong in the force they just sort of
drowned his signal out so that the
emperor couldn't find him but it also
served his biological needs for his race
because he needed to live in a swamp
like environment we know they're
extremely long-lived but because of that
they reproduce very infrequently and
there are always very very few of them
in the galaxy at any one time there's no
actual count even Master Yoda probably
doesn't know how many members of his
race currently exist but when they're
born they're all born with relatively
high force sensitivity so if you do want
to talk about midi-chlorians yes you
mean you can make all the jokes that you
want but they're all born with
relatively high counts just like Master
Yoda was that's why everyone is always
so curious about them the Emperor the
rest of the Imperials baby Yoda even
tries to heal the Mandalorian with the
force just to give you an idea
for how innately force-sensitive and
powerful he is he's not old enough to
speak but he knows enough about the
force that he knows that he can use it
to heal his wound even though the
Mandalorian himself seems like he
doesn't know anything about the ways of
the force even if he grew up during the
Clone Wars which we know he did because
of the flashbacks my assumption there is
that because his parents seemed like
they were killed during the Clone Wars
and he went into refuge he became a
foundling as part of these Mandalorian
clans that they just didn't spend a lot
of time teaching him about Force Lord
because most the Jedi got wiped out
during the purge him learning about the
force by watching baby Yoda do crazy WTF
things will probably just play out over
the rest of the season and if baby Yoda
is doing stuff like this now at the
beginning of the series
think about what they might be saving in
terms of big WTF force moments for the
series finale if you're really excited
about what's going on with the series
right now don't worry they just started
filming season two a little while ago so
unless they say something different I'm
assuming the season two episodes will
drop next year around the same time and
by that time most places around the
world will have access to Disney Plus so
you won't all have to race around to
find the episode somewhere else every
single week when they drop them my
Mandalorian episode 3 video will post
tomorrow after the episode airs so be
sure to watch it however you can watch
the episode while you wait for that
everyone click here for my Star Wars
Mandalorian episode 2 video and click
here for my brand new Rick and Morty
season 4 episode 3 trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!